[Music]
you adopted a puppy yeah from BuzzFeed
thank you guys for this adorable puppy I
haven't seen it she's here actually um I
should have brought back to the question
that's the question what's the question
Diane that's it Diana chapter of Jonas
yeah is the name of the dog yeah she's
adopted both of us she's a rescue we
were doing an interview with BuzzFeed
she was one of multiple puppies that
they Unleashed on me and I was supposed
to answer questions they were all so
cute but she like was chewing on my
Burberry shoes and then just lay here
and fell asleep and I was like
take her home the next day I took her
home I
wonder where the puppies are both
BuzzFeed show me the where are Sam's
puppies I want puppies too